everyone my name presenti who don't know
me as a mr. Jesse and the associate
director of the master's program in or
on the street here this event is part of
our ongoing workshop series which goes
through the academic year interview that
last one and Jennifer wanted to go out
and we bring together people who are
working in the field of oral history and
that the edges avanafil that overlap
with wildest dream really trying to
showcase some of the most cutting-edge
work that's happening and so we're
really thrilled about Jennifer here
today to talk has been generously
co-sponsored by the institute for
research and african-american studies
and the MA program using meth apology
here as part of the paul lazarsfeld
lecture series and so I want to just
before we start I like that we've got
two events coming up next week that some
of you might be interested in that I'll
pass around and flyers for both of them
we have a two day conference oral
history and our times that's going to
highlight work of the Center for Orleans
Street month a detention rendition and
Guantanamo and a little bit stuck in
there on Thursday morning on jazz
Orleans tree which should be really
fantastic and another the afternoon of
thursday is going to be a celebration
and reflection for
anniversary of our oral history master
of arts program and so the culmination
that will be a showcase of multimedia
Orleans Street showcase of student work
from the students in the current reward
and with the wine and cheese and also
champagne and cake reception so and
you're all very welcome to attend and so
let me just introduce to her the world
through the frigid to you at Jennifer's
anthropologist public historian and
curator she serves as the vice director
and director of research at the
Samaritan Center and she spearheads the
oral history project and conducting one
of the few workshops and served at
Worlds two advisory boards including
story for 30 before she worked at
weeksville she worked with City lures
place matters project and the lower east
side of manhattan to document
place-based stories and develop new
place making strategies and approaches
she teaches courses right now in
cultural anthropology ethnology material
cultural heritage and museum site of the
new school is teaching to us with your
soda for the busy time Parsons and Pat
Institute is a contributor to a number
of publications including most recently
the vodka museum democracy dialogue and
debate and Jennifer holds degrees from
Stanford University the University of
California Los Angeles and the
University of Michigan so welcome thank
you very much I'm going to share your
work with us and what's whatever to make
your material thank you Amy and Aaron
Marshall Clark of the Masters
trans-pacific great conversation
talk about week till and what we're
doing there um what I wanted to do today
is kind of give you an overview of how
you know we are wasteful some even our
head start and also are an overview our
project and this and then a specific
direction towards activism that sort of
happening organically so it's not it's
sort of some kind of thinking about
cooking penis preliminary research but
I'm interested in getting a feedback I
think about the festivities and maybe in
the queuing discussions who could talk
about different experiences with your
friends should work in approaching these
kind of topics um so a mutual heritage
center represents a history that had
been completely erased and the community
struggle was fought for and reclaimed in
the 1960s um oral history as you all
know I'm sure lens really nicely to
actually try to feel you know what
people perceive as gaps and also what
we've been learning over the years is
that there's a lot of distortions well
so it also helps to come some nuances
that will correct and those distortions
and confront distortions a little bit um
so we the way that we design our own
history project feel free to come on and
let me know just start
so we figured out a way to approach our
own the street project and then what
happens if which often happens is that
certain teams come up that just sort of
organically it could recognizes patterns
on certain angles and you have a few
those that have been happening once
we've been talking to people over the
years one of those is activated so I'm
going to give you an op- comprehensive
list or view of all those participants
but I under give you a glimpse of how
that's happening um and what's been
really important I think in that regard
is it's showing us an answer to a
question that we get asked a lot because
weeks little is in many people's lives
of success story in terms of 1962 be
able to fight our history and as you
know in New York you know always having
Theresa with preservation and having
different voices represented so we often
get asked you know how we still can't
beat how it emerged house is possible
and so we want to want to think more
about that to be able to present people
that the contemporary possibilities
today what you could possibly do
wherever you are in terms of being a
catalyst for change and what we've been
seeing is that these things didn't
happen isolation it was part of the
climate at the time a lot of people came
to wheatsville were part of different
movements but welcome to myself and also
um weeksville and their efforts at least
cells were really an extension of their
activism across the board so this is
week sale on my assets earlier but how
many of you have been here all the weeks
go yeah Pacific storehouses they date
approximately from the 1840s to the
1980s we've restored the interiors for
three different time periods 1816 the
1900s this is what we're using
temporarily as our offices which you
cannot see this image is tightly our
almost a full city block green space
right now construction site of a 40
million dollar building that's almost
finished the green space will be
landscape to 19th century agricultural
features to park it back to the time of
the original Weeksville residents
this is a mission um we are aiming to
document preserve and interpret the
history of people of African descent in
Brooklyn and Louisville and Beyond and
everything that we do is rooted in
history we're very adamant about that
but also everything has a contemporary
connection and this is also where all of
the street can be really helpful because
it lets us know how people are seeing
the past what the past means to them how
they can connect the present to past if
people do that in all sorts of different
ways so weak still up through historic
research tours programs at the Museum we
interpret what we call forgotten history
Weeksville a free flap intentional and
online community which established its
own schools churches anti-slavery
organizations and operate as a safe
space where people of African descent
and the greater new york area throughout
the 19th century and this is a history
that I can said earlier nobody knew
about people who didn't do very little
so it's a very important industry I'm
not going to talk too much about that
19th century mystery date but I
encourage you to take the tour come to
visit weeksville go to the houses and
your rental stores we are great
educators um I also want to mention that
we're kind of we kind of tell the story
of two histories so there's a 19th
century history and then equally
important is the 1960s late 1960s 1970s
rediscovery story of that history and
that's mostly what I'm
focus on today we use a simple matrices
as a clich now from dolores Hayden's
book power plates we use the power place
to trigger memories and basically people
see the tangible culture to see the
architecture and they remember what they
do in the neighborhood how they interact
but used to be here and so we use the
we're very lucky in that sense what we
use is tangible culture basically to
reduce these memories just to locate
which school is located in what's called
central Brooklyn oh I had wanted to show
you but anyway this there was a little
circle to show so here's weeksville we
are in crown heights technically they
used to be meant to die besten crown
heights are our closest neighborhood
they're one of the interesting things oh
it's been happening we still disappear
from the maps all together at a certain
point and now we're starting to see that
we're back on the maps so we like to
think that these memories that people
have been filling in relationship to the
center and the effort that have actually
been recreated in place literally and
putting the place on the map okay so
this is classic central Brooklyn you
have you know these beautiful
brownstones impact abundance of churches
very close-knit neighborhoods
predominantly african-american Harvey an
African immigrant residents alongside a
sizable Hasidic Jewish community and
after world war two you had a lot of
people of African descent coming from
the southern part of the US as well as
the Caribbean and are almost each
represents that diversity
this is actually a non kingsborough
houses right across the street so
Brooklyn is known for these rich multi
cultural and physical resources but at
the same time the area is also known for
and this is not for no reason without
reason a number of challenges high crime
and sufficient infrastructure racial
tension of poverty and accessibility as
some of you were mentioning earlier at
the conflict and also just a really
disparaging reputation and it's actually
only recently that Brooklyn has become a
hot place to be in to live which is
consistent with this tremendous way of
gentrification that's happening right
now that's pricing out people that is
that I think it's like around nine
billion dollars that are being invested
in Brooklyn and I forget how many poured
out the rest residents in a very short
time span and i'm sure those of you
familiar with brooklyn i've seen a lot
of that so it's very much on our minds
it's very much on people's minds these
changes and and I'm just saying all this
so you know the context of wish we're
producing these are all histories but
people are very concerned about things
place of course and also the character
of the neighborhood changing not just
physically but also population lines and
so all this tree again is very key and
happening people's memories because it's
one of the most useful ways to make the
invisible visible in that sense whether
people are able to stay or not and we
want people to be able to stay not to
force out but the weeksville itself and
history was completely forgotten in many
ways we know that the history sort of
being erased front of our eyes so that's
one of those things what we're trying to
pay attention and be attentive about how
we approach it
okay so the nice and 68 this is a big
here just you've all probably know New
York history very well but after the
nineteen fifties after war to the city
of many cities began to experience white
fight what's called white flight to the
suburbs with the client business and
traditional industries which were moving
outside of New York places like New
Jersey long island of his horse space so
naturally this left of lawyer in
working-class areas there's an increase
in crime and that accompanied with the
official crisis in the 1970s with seals
Claire bankruptcy was the state of
affairs of alongside all of this there
was a building boom happening post-1950
but at the same time lots of buildings
were being torn down to make way for new
developments so this is definitely the
case in bedford-stuyvesant crown heights
area to the certain free robux abilities
so New York put in the 1960s was
experiences gradual economic and social
decay series of labor strikes president
teachers including the famous book
shovel brownsville strike which one
mentioned a little bit later and also
1968 you know very big year because
Martin Luther King was a centering that
April kennedy is assassinated three
years before Malcolm X is assassinated
in New York you have the the house a
impact the civil rights act 1968 sign as
well so you know there's a lot going on
this is a very charged time and I just
say all these things as reminders
because this is when weak souls history
as we discover so it'll make sense the
kind of stories that have come up in
interviews that what about necessarily
civil rights and activism but there's so
many connections
that ground they what happened this week
ok so the hunter playground houses were
rediscovered in 1968 although Jim Hurley
who's here to the right tells us it
technically a few years before because
he was already doing research well he
was a volunteer at college instructor at
pratt institute and there were handful
students like Dolores and cola here on
the Left who were parts that they call a
central neighborhood college study
course that was working on a
neighborhood servic project and looking
into these two store communities which
they did a little about one of the ways
that we didn't if they walk around the
neighborhood and we just looked at me we
actually are getting a lot of slides
right now that show of people show you
know Dolores and Jim and Pat Johnson
others who were involved walking around
the infinite looking at things in under
in disrepair so they were figuring out
the boundaries of the area generally and
then they were looking for architectural
evidence so one of the ways that they
did this is that Joe Hayes is here I was
an engineer for MTA and then he also had
a pilot's license so he they rented a
plane a prop plane from teterboro
airport and they flew over the area
actually looking for architectural
evidence of historic week silk and this
is similar to what they saw it we
actually know the aerial views that we
from them taking pictures in the plane
this is actually probably from the top
of the Senior Center which was a tall
building of kings really shows you so
this is what they saw these three houses
which are now
houses are perpendicular to this vein
road and that's usually a sign that it
predates the modern 19th century 4th
Street system and indeed it did as it
turns out it was a portion Nick seat
colonial Dutch colonial world so this is
sort of a row though how people are
guessing the road went through out kings
county before you had the grid system
applied to this area in symptoms and
before that it was a native american
trade pact so you know people are very
excited about this discovery is not too
long after the discovery they learned
that they were going to be torn down of
course through an urban renewal project
called model cities and not these houses
first first it was block of houses that
were a couple streets away from under
fire road houses and Jim Hurley we've
done his oral history tells the story
literally he saw the headlines one night
he immediately wrote a telegram which we
now have a copy of telling her he sent a
telegram for people who've never seen a
telegram it looks very much alike this
point social media news but he basically
insisted that they stop the demolition
and that they at least allowed
investigation of the side the history
and you can imagine in the spirit charge
time people finally learn of this
history they finally go to the area
there they think they know where it is
and they finally have a chance to learn
about it and all the physical evidence
is going to be torn down so um Tom and
they were going to make a way for the
for a new housing project which is now
public school gardens so they were not
able to halt the demolition they all
pulled strings and do whatever they
include they were not in the halted but
they were allowed to do an
archaeological excavation of those
houses so these are images from 1968 and
this shows you the the intergenerational
participation you had kids you got Boy
Scouts you have school children from
across the street from kids 243 we still
work with you had scholars you had every
day residency and Activision of people
who became activists through this effort
so is a very broad spectrum of people
who got involved and and just so you put
this in a little bit of perspective she
all known about the African very room
okay and I never know asked my classes
some time later um this this is to you
know that there's the controversy that
happened like a 10 year of communities
struggle to save if and that history
stop that that construction so this
archaeological excavation is 23 years
before that which is incredibly
pioneering I mean we're talking about
extremely elite disciplines preservation
archaeology um very elite disciplines
that you don't usually see dis approach
eyes communities participating in and
you had people full force participating
figuring it out learning it and making
it happens and this is the passion of
the love
commitment at the time so we have all
these great photos color and
black-and-white of people who were
involved in this effort the
schoolchildren were essential there's a
young Jim early in the background there
and this is peace PS 243 which became
the week's book school this was a
cupboard and 19 I mean with the cover it
was chained the name was changed in 1978
and it's actually a direct descendant of
colored school number two which was the
second african fries you when people
African descent were excluded from
education and school secretary and
that's what was located in weeksville so
it's it's a very important historical
institution as well and one that that
weeks largest center continually works
with two for all of our program so the
school was very involved in the
archaeological digs they had a
mini-museum as well um this is dr.
evelyn castro was a teacher at the time
and i want to play a clip because i
think that her part of her or history
represents understanding a little bit of
how activism works and the kind of forms
of active that activism tanks and i was
at a conference i don't know if you all
tended
surely last fall but Louisa passerini
art memory in stroke waconia eyes I'm
consciousnesses and she said something I
really resonated with me was which was
oral history the critical work of oral
histories to a road illusions and I
think that especially for additional
franchise communities that's really
important to confront stereotypes as
much as possible and so the clip that I
gotta play is from Evelyn has been
talking about what this excavation what
the three discovery meant to people in
terms of confronting stereotypes and
thinks credit cards and kids it it's a
definitely kind of activism organ
University and volunteer morning
otherwise get the New York Times
delivered and we never been used on Tori
I was reading on cold front page of
tangent at 66 Tyrus and get up Frank so
I I called home and I said mom we live
in again wouldn't you know is that me
because I always lived in a house in
browser I mother didn't work pathology
all my sisters and brothers are going to
school my parents both said were a cop
even went to my mother actually married
while at the three years concert they
went to college I piano lessons Girl
Scouts I had no idea that people on the
outside considered really loop and who
we were as part of what did she say me
one st run she said that that's not
really the case that we are a community
and we have a lot of things that we were
doing to support our children and
seniors and that that racism exists
people will look at us in a certain way
but we know who we are and I found that
when I I wanted to teach in bedside and
that's how I picked the Isaac Newton
school which became weak sauce school
and I found that the same stereotypes
existed of what people thought about the
kids and who they were and not to say
that we didn't have kids who was
struggling economically but their
standards in who they were so I found
that the weeks of digs and the things
that we were doing to go across this you
to the vacant lot and do those things
pieces of china pieces of glass and to
tell the story of weeks ago so she for
young children didn't any tactile things
making butter or quilting a camera
making it helped them to connect to
their pants grandma so important thing
for me is that Evelyn Castro like a lot
of other people who interviewed directly
connect the getting involved was
grateful as a kind of activism that
changes stereotypes and corrects these
distortions of perceptions we find that
that's coming up a lot in Orion in our
interviews um so people took the
evidence that they were getting up the
evidence that they were getting from the
excavation and they brought them to use
to actually save the Hunter flied road
houses which were also threatened by
English but this time you know that the
end of that we actually win so these
this is you know before Twitter and
Facebook where people were putting a
call out for people to come and testify
and this is sort of you know I can say
this is part of the oral tradition that
we're talking about as well with oral
histories that are part of getting
people to come and testify about this
history we know so much more about this
history than the other time and they
were still going out to the right as an
image of the Boy Scouts with the back of
artifacts way to test whether we've been
looking for that testimony we've gone
everywhere I can't seem to locate it but
we haven't given up hope people say
about the children about the kids which
so wouldn't have happened because of
their testimony we were made a new york
city landmark in 1971 and then also
perfected on the national register for
Historic Places of the houses stay
standing and and you know the next
preparing and making sure that continue
so there was after all these different
stages of trying to secure this history
reclaim it one of the things that people
did was try to collect stories so the
first oil history effort actually began
the collaboration of Medgar Evers and
where we're trying to reconstruct as
much of what how this process was
approaches as possible we're actually
rediscovering our own archives and
trying to figure out what happened but
there were about at least as far as we
can see about 25 or 30 interviews done
with longtime residents like Harriet and
laying here to the right picture from
when she's older trying to get their
memories down and documented right away
and I won't go into details but when
when those audio cassettes were
rediscovered just think shoe box smash
etc most of them survived and I'm happy
to say today we actually have all of
them that have survived our digitized
and transcribed so they're preserved and
we made that a priority
two thousand three years old so Harriet
Elaine is an interesting oral history
because we don't have an audio recording
of her and we have these handful of
handwritten memories as well her family
when she died also donated things that
are part of the family like her wedding
dress and her beaded persons and the
family bibles we have also personal
items associated with this this history
before she'd of it she would almost a
hundred she wrote at the age of 89 a six
page essay called this is what i know
about Weeksville where she talks about
everything she knows new six pages and a
lot of them are institutions that are
part of its with history and how she
associated it with in what she was part
of church groups on she talks a lot
about the school this is colored school
number two and also a derivation of
Spiritu pious 83 that is now PS 243 so
we have a handful of these actual
autobiographical letters on Bayon our
messages here today and I think we have
less than 10
keep steadily across them so we're sort
of considering that is also part of this
effort okay so um what we've been doing
is restarting along history project and
we're trying to figure out the best way
to do that considering these two
histories in 19th century 1960s we're
not going to interrupt and so what we've
done is basically target for groups the
founders who are involved in the early
excavations the rediscovery the
preservation efforts etc people who
actually lived in the specific
storehouses they can be descendants of
people who live there in the 19th
century or they could live in there
themselves we have been trying to track
people down people kind of show up at
the door and we try to record them
relatives or historic figures there's a
number of people in weeksville that were
on the Nationals anti-slavery their
journalists there were pastors etc and
so some of their descendants are around
we are we're trying to interview them so
these are more traditional ways of
approaching or mr. Fisher and then our
biggest category which were you know
we're still getting through is long time
for clean residents and the ideas we
just don't know what's out there we
don't know
kind of stories are out there to tell so
we don't really want to limit it fully
but we sort of have to prioritize and
figure out how to approach okay so I
that's where the overview of our project
today we have 130 oral histories
collected and we have them most of them
are almost all wood transcribed and
digitized and we're trying to stick with
that because we want to make them
accessible in arming center so this is
this one of the things that has been
coming up as I mentioned earlier is that
the people who have come to leave school
especially the founder category but not
exclusively some people might have just
live in the neighborhood we're very
steep and a lot of different activist
activities and so the next segment of
the presentation is to show you a
glimpse of those things coming up so
this again is Jim Hurley Delores the
colas we've interviewed them several
times remember them and that's them in
front of the houses I'm going to fix hip
one of the things that comes up a lot is
just how everyday people were involved
in the struggle instead of breaking down
this definition of what it means to be a
community struggle and how they were
able to be resourceful and do it they
needed to do whatever it took so I'm
just going to play that quickly and
you'll hear Dolores McClellan's voice
I'll Canada we also have to realize that
this was a community effort people who
actually started with sir you all just
annuity people we've had
phe they didn't come until later on okay
there were people that I worked in
courthouse I was a court reporter in
downtown Brooklyn in civil Supreme Court
and I you a lot of people downtown so we
were able to get things done just bikers
who knew we had to find things there was
a man Wilson witness who was a boy scout
leader here in Brooklyn Wilson now is an
elderly gentleman he's lost spoke of his
legs and his voice chat we had
archaeological dig digging up stuff in
the beginning from these same houses in
this area so what I like this this clip
it represents the number of segments and
different oral histories that we've been
collecting where people are actually
demystifying the organizing process a
little bit and showing how you can do
what you can do where you are and I
think that's a very strong benefit of
oral history work to hear how it was
done so that you can see but it's doable
okay so um John Boehner if some of you
was our matrix for about 30 years she is
an artist and illustrator she led the
effort to and to keep them standing and
you know I don't know that many people
know how she had gotten involved I think
she's a great example of someone who
wasn't necessarily didn't I say we
started out as an activist but became an
activist year basically committed her
life to week silken history she was very
very into the children learning there is
only her history history claiming it you
know flying portrayals etc etc so how
did she she's excited all she was
connected to many other cultural and
arts organizations that were also very
politically minded and another person
that we interviewed Esther Cooper
Jackson to talks about her relationship
drama Esther Cooper Jackson moved to New
York in the 1950s from Virginia she was
raised in segregated schools of course
she came to New York she worked with the
Sun southern Negro youth congress in
virginia and then in birmingham
alabama's organized black women tobacco
workers and steel workers she was
involved with countless labor
demonstrations and by the 1940s she
completed a master's thesis eventually
on domestic worker she wanted to said
she wanted run her PhD that she got
distracted by practice in college she
helped with coal organizing drives and
spent a summer working on
voting campaign um when she moved to New
York she found it freedom ways with WB
bogeys in 1961 and this is a journal
that's noted as the central theoretical
journal 20th century Black Arts and
intellectual movement in the United
States on freedom ways covered local
national and international political
debates liberation movements of the day
and lasted for 25 years and if you look
closely Casey who the illustrators it's
joe manor generator was an illustrator
for a number of the free of voice
journals there's a very important arts
and cultural journal so Esther Cooper
Jackson talks about those connections
and I just want to play a couple clips
where she talks about supporting artists
and while they were part of these
organizations artists like Joan but then
also has she met Joan oh and we thought
it was important of that me of all the
artists in the rights of poets along the
historians of the civil rights activist
and this is lovely wanted this was in
our first editorial on the precision we
make very clear that was what we wanted
to give to united front to fight police
important issues in black America and
having a joke become involved with the
drum but what I think she saw they like
many of the artists of the period
started coming around up to I don't
recall whether she was at the first
event but
imagine some of these next we have
debates poetry readings we ever played
on hold of all Broadway we thought was
important we buy here for two nights and
endeavour thought raise money for the
same times amazingly I guess she's just
a warm wonderful human being she stood
when I didn't get to clubbing that
sometimes I get a packet of the peer in
that she sent me from things she was
doing but I was busy doing other things
and I consider her really a personal
friend even though we worked up you know
sometimes needs to go by so forth a
certain ones I didn't see her but Diana
and she was deeply involved with being
vice so people who know John Maynard
know her as a successful person and they
don't know the context that created her
produced her and she was exceptional
person for sure but it doesn't mean that
there can be other exceptional people so
one of the benefits of oral history is
showing how people created these these
networks in these webs these political
intellectual cultural webs that would
support one another and provide well
mentum into doing something like
rediscovering and creating a week's film
it becomes part of their activism so we
want again we want to encourage people
that it's possible to be a joint you
know you can start off she has a
beginning like a lot of us do and a
formation and so you know again they
really help to mystify that process I
think you can see that there's all sorts
of ways to get there Elsie Richardson
is another person you might know her or
heard about she was a community activist
who was very much involved as supporters
of leesville she passed away fairly
recently unfortunately she was the
leader and the co-founder of something
called the CBC see which started 1952
the central Brooklyn Coordinating
Committee a coalition of over 90
community organizations working to
improve Black Brooklyn socio-economic
conditions during a time that was
rampant with social lives according to a
historian Brian for now these social
ills identified his cramped housing
stock insufficient health services
inadequate youth programming over at
overcrowded schools and infrequent
sanitation services CVCC eventually led
to the creation of the best I
restoration corporation first bed early
and privately funded community
development corporation in the country
begun then by robert f kennedy and
intended to be a model for combating
urban poverty LC the very publicized
walk through the neighborhood with
kennedy to evaluate the neighborhood
conditions and there's been a lot
written about this um Elfi was one of
the founders we consider one of the
founders of the original weeksville
society she helped to facilitate the
original excavation that revealed
weeksville artifacts discovered during
the demolition
is that I mentioned and she was also
critical in helping with some purchases
the historic houses through the
assistance of bed-stuy restoration
corporation so again you see all these
connections these things are not
whistles not happening in isolation
happening and you know with what one
person has told me that I did it was in
the air activism was in the air she said
if you weren't involved something was
wrong with you actually this is the
person said that this is a very well
this is her daughter Sharon mulch who is
that's a picture of her that's the cusum
famous epic so she's holding one of the
coins found at the archaeological
excavation Benny watch came to Rick's go
through what she calls education
activism so some her daughter was a
student at peace 243 involved in the
archaeological excavation and actually
is now teacher Maryland and attributes
her her commitment to education from
this whole experience and that's we also
get a lot of that in all history the
world history of the impact with this
time a Don people which I think it's
really important for people to remember
so the whole reason is her abalone
complicate started the whole reason that
Sharon ended up in peace 243 the weeks
of school was through her mother's
involvement with ocean hill Brownsville
month-long teachers strike in New York
which I won't go into I know some of you
might have heard or heard about her
studied about it but basically it was
challenging discriminatory educational
this isn't trying to be centralized if
you should put more power in the hands
of parents and teachers and they're all
sort of he listened to many losses or
this week through a whole sort of turn
of events eventually she put Sharon
against 243 where she heard
presentations end by Jim Hurley and
that's how she got involved with
weeksville it was right up her alley in
terms of education and teaching also as
an interesting kind of side enough it's
actually trying to get this for me these
presentations and it was not working out
the AFT what a large teachers union in
the country supported the march on
Washington and participated in the event
as many of you may know it so happens
that Betty Welch's and this is after
dying her for so many years you know
that's another thing you do these
repeated oral histories we find all
those new information the point why
don't you topless um Betty Welch's uncle
who learned like last year work for the
New York City police force and was the
first black super chief of the NYPD
before becoming super cheap he used to
work security for Coretta Scott King and
as a result he has this incredible color
footage the owner color footage I've
ever seen of the march on Washington
from his own sort of video making where
he documents himself his son and his son
is actually holding the camera while
he's talking and he's working security
at the Martin you see all these other
they are afflicted were these fezzes and
its eye level of the march on Washington
so you know none of this is coincidental
all this is part of the moment
that is is making people want to defend
history Weeksville and conserve the site
for future generations enlist I just had
to include this for all the stories in
the room I just love this so you know if
you haven't done if you haven't done all
this you work for you account for people
who are worried about saying the wrong
thing and getting things wrong you will
eventually but one of the ways that
plays out is that they're worried they
don't know the dates of things and that
they're wrong and they don't dare you
not an expert on their own history so
this is sort of an answer jokes bad
because we discovered the last interview
that we did a video will turn your home
that she has say every calendar of her
life since the 1970s and so she I you
know I'd be in a city or thoughts on a
pushing this isn't some kind of world
history project she was going through
meetings she forgot that she went she
could tell you the exact day that
meetings happen organization she would
launcher that she forgot just by her
calendars she was a huge box of them and
so you know for those of us to keep
calories you don't always go to the
things on the calendar so i think
interested in that of an oral history
project such as a super senator
record but you know we didn't even take
too much evidence has take a picture of
her almira in here we attack or see a
AmeriCorps seat passed away also
recently this is her daughter Henrietta
who happens to be an educator outside
New York City Benny Welch work closely
with amira she was the assistant to the
vice chancellor of urban affairs at New
York Community City College and
according to many worlds responsible for
helping Jim Hurley to relocate what was
then called the project weeksville to an
educational institution which was the
New York City Community College's pearl
building located in downtown Brooklyn
community members collaborating with New
York City Community College to help
catalog artifacts from the jig
investigate institution
we fell in collect world history and
exhibitions were also mounted to garner
attention and support for the project
and what it's very well to set it on
Myra courses that without her help there
would be no mix well everything that
happened in the block community of
Brooklyn at that time she was involved
in and reported back to the
vice-chancellor and this image is of you
know a lot of movers and shakers Alma
Carol in front was part of our jazz
orchestra project connection but this
image documents the renaming ceremony of
an amphitheater after on my writing
herbert von heart event starring 2011 to
acknowledge your contributions to the
development of the park and her lifelong
dedication to community service so again
lots of activist and lots of connections
this is just an image of the first major
exhibit of the projects finding mountain
in New York City Community College
Library in December 1969 this is william
t harley who was a lifelong resident of
bed-stuy also one of the co-founders and
the heads of the archaeological project
the exhibit was extended through 1970 by
popular demand and i put this in here
because another movement that's
connected two weeks till his college
activism because just in 1969 a year
later you have college activism
demanding Black Studies departments
sweeping across
tree so this is say who Lewis Jeffy he
came to weave stroll through the college
student activism in brooklyn new york he
he was organizing 244 more
african-american faculty for Black
Studies and while he was attending year
City Community College's he says in an
interview we were involved in the late
sixties developing relevant programs for
students one was the African American
history program in a women's program in
a Latino history program there we met
with a lot of resistance but we as its
took the hallways and really campaign
very hard for programs or relevance of
black folks and it took us two years but
we got an African American history
program and he went on while he was in
college to work with william t Carly
Gustav and currently on archiving and
catalyzing the party the archaeological
objects found from the excavation um he
it also so happens he was a big
supporter of a black nationalist
organization that we've heard of called
the east it's located in bed-stuy used
to put on all sorts of very famous music
programs um he said in his interview
very much respected the independent
black schools as well as the National
Black together I think he is also the
actor he said where I in fact crafted
the art
so I think it's an interesting ways
connecting all these different parts of
information even as worthless weeks
these are the pictures of the east and
the each had its own independent what
school this is jocelyn cooper squared
this is jessica cooper senior josh
jocelyn cooper junior Oh Jonathan Cooper
senior is a community activist and her
family is very important they have made
a huge impact of civil rights in Black
Brooklyn her late husband Andrew Cooper
this is a recent book that just came out
who was a beer company employee
journalist and political columnist suvi
york state officials in the landmark
cakes Cooper vs Power challenging the
arrangement of congressional districts
charging that for black citizens were
denied the right to elect an authentic
representative on their community and
when in the case the court issue of 12th
district be redrawn creating a new seat
which made it possible for shirley
Chisholm part of Cooper's political club
to run for that seat and become the
first lifelong member of Congress and
some of you might know inconsistency
real important newspaper and Rupert was
also the family of something called the
city sun seun the black dog newspaper
was modeled are speaking truth to power
which we have represented a very strong
political points and then Jocelyn and
Rupert so so Jocelyn Cooper cedar it's a
very good friend of John Maynard very
big supporter of Louisville and Jocelyn
Cooper jr. we I don't even say quits
identities none of this is towards we
work with very much in our programming
she's one of the geniuses behind Africa
and we do a lot of programming so see
him shirley Chisholm shirley Chisholm
there she is she was very involved also
right there at the beginning to
harlingen early with supporting
Weeksville we have several lovely images
of her with blue mt Harley there's one
of John Mayer in her possession here
with this lovely portrait okay this is
the final this is Paris Robertson he
grew up in Weeksville neighborhood he
tended local schools in university and
he's also currently a member of Dweezil
here to Center for directors I like to
you know have this could be the last has
a very easy lovely person um first of
all but he has a very interesting part
of his interview where he's talking
about what it means to be an activist
and why he's involved in all the things
that he's involved with and I and I
think again it's one of the benefits of
oral history to not just sort of get
what you think happened to what you
remember happened with also what it
means
I don't believe that you have a right to
do nothing in life I think the person
that does nothing is stealing it from us
you know just no reason to agree if you
just walk through life and never have an
impact I've got a schoolboy pushing a
Brownsville I worked as executive over
there I worked a school board member in
Vegas eric brown eyes district 17 I've
been with government staff you carry as
a program associate that work with the
problem district attorney as a director
of alternative sentencing which is a
whole nother story I've been president
of the Urban League in Brooklyn without
the years my wife is very involved with
her would be retired teachers and
principals so she was a suit of Debbie's
lieutenant and so we have a merry of all
the patients participating because we
believe individually and collectively
sounds awesome if you live here you
should be involved with run four
hormones I've done all kinds of
readiness reaches achieve out there and
it's all about taking responsibility for
who you are away haha you know he's a
very normal person I this is one of the
downsides of doing these sound bites and
editing out of context
um so so anyway I mean this is this is
this is typical imps of what we should I
me and one of the persons I wanted to
raise doing all this we've never done it
all out let's do it all this trade
initiative project on activism and in
some ways we haven't had to but the fact
that it keeps coming up I'm wondering
how much and how much as we lost if we
did do that I mean I know that you know
flowers Holly and say oh we're doing a
you know project of civil rights we're
doing a project you know this week's
will have any anything to contribute and
we're like everything is healthy because
it comes up so often so I'm not sure
that it would actually be beneficial
because if you just focus on that does
that mean you lose the context of what
what causes people to be participants in
these struggles so you know so far we
haven't done anything but that's just
something I wanted to raise for
discussion you know so these are kind of
the stories that have been and what they
filling the landscape because I've been
there but these these stories with you
know we feel like they they're allowing
us to build relationships with people
rebuild relationships with people so far
so far they've been working well for
less but for us to sustain you know
these relationships but just to show you
some contemporary issues contemporary
images of weeks felt beyond the story
native tradition you know there's a how
the spaces users
traditions this is the opening of dance
Africa through brooklyn academy of music
always is always a week cells now open
to the public we have music concerts we
have this our audience at one of our
garden party series farmers market I
mean is this the voices that are at
Atlantis cases people that are adding to
the landscapes with the traditions of I
don't think that stories and doing our
listeners of the only way I think they
all sort of fill this landscape and help
us to create community so I just wanted
to show the context of course education
and children are a big part of weeks
build these are kids during an equal
height project and this is weeksville in
the near future because 19,000 square
foot building we talked about it a
little bit before there will be
everything that we do a week soldiers of
programming will be expanded so we have
to education classrooms we have a
contemporary art gallery we have a
performing art space we have a sound
studio that made SS and all history
studio and everything of the media lab
ok a resource center that hopefully
these these interiors of the main
available but you know we can talk more
about what we plan to do with the growth
history work but basically everything is
like I said earlier everything I would
do we're trying to encourage
participation and democratization of
this history and just to make sure that
would happen before
again the people want to preserve the
history that they're able to do that on
their own terms so self determination to
people and they think this is one of our
construction shots of them the real site
the other one is sketch but we're much
further along with is there Justin
landscaping now so everyone should come
out take tools